last august members of wimbledon labour
party met here to discuss which
definition of anti-semitism
they thought the national party should
adopt but during the debate comments
were made
which prompted a number of complaints
they came during an intervention made by
sir duncan michael
a labour member for many years who was
knighted for services to engineering in
2001.
sky news has obtained an audio recording
of his comments
this storm started straight after we
used the jelly
directly at him including
very undemocratically from within our
party
and the reason corbin is kindly to
palestine
and others attacking foreign and so the
jewish community
plans to attack our party
[Music]
the comments were challenged at the
meeting by one of the speakers on the
panel
glenn sekker a member of the pro corbin
group jewish voice for labour
i don't believe you're anti-semitic i
think you're
informed and i would want to have a
discussion with you
too
[Music]
several complaints were submitted to
labour after the meeting but in october
complainants received this email from
the regional office
saying after taking this case through
our anti-semitism process
the labour party does not believe this
is an incident of anti-semitism
and will not be taken further the jewish
labor movement say that decision
is not acceptable talking about an
undemocratic elite talking about the
jews acting as a whole community to
attack the labour party
that really plays into some of the
oldest anti-semitic tropes about jews
being conspiratorial and acting in
secrecy as some sort of cult
to try and influence politics earlier
this week after a request from the
parliamentary labour party
general secretary jenny formby set out
details of how anti-semitism claims have
been handled since last april
as a result of the 673 complaints that
were received in relation to labour
members
96 people were suspended and 12 were
expelled from the party but it was also
revealed
that in 220 cases there was judge to be
not enough
evidence to proceed with an
investigation one of the labour mps
who's been pressuring the party to act
more decisively
says more action must follow we will be
pursuing the party
on a whole range of individual cases and
this will
be one of them and what is interesting
is that when an individual case is
raised with the labour party
they seem to miraculously change their
mind
uh in the face of a public
a public comment on the case labour said
they would not comment on individual
cases but in a statement a spokesman
said
the labour party takes all complaints of
anti-semitism extremely seriously
and we're committed to challenging and
campaigning against it in all its forms
all complaints about anti-semitism are
fully investigated in line with our
rules and procedures
and any appropriate disciplinary action
is taken
however a labor source has suggested a
national investigation
is ongoing into the comments and claimed
the message sent to complainants telling
them no further action was being taken
may have been sent in error sir duncan
was approached for comment
but did not respond tom rayner sky news
westminster